mon coeur c'est au bout du monde et moi
je vis au jour le jour
comptant les aides et les secondes le
séparant de ton retour quand on se
reverra m'a viré les draps
et je cesserai mai aps le vrai de toi
moment près de toi en trouve en
oublierait joue les héris les honneurs à
dans nos coeurs la marche
les ans
la france je prie le ciel
mr le pays de mon enfance pour tu ne me
rappelais espérer quand on se veut
la virade et rats et je sais je rêve non
moi moment près de toi approuvant le bli
résout désiré zone radar doppler la
marche
oh
ja
victoires et places dans les années
passées pour l'amour a vécu sans gloire
bien
avec pas
le temps
m
là
c'est cher
même là près de toi moment
je ne sais pas
non
la rochelle
[Musique]
ja